[Musique]
2012 a médina aux états unis donc à
l'époque j'étais en fac américaine et
donc je les regardais avec toutes mes
coéquipières de l'équipe
on était trois européennes et tout le
reste américaine bien sûr donc on était
un petit peu en infériorité numérique
mais du coup c'est ça qui a apporté un
petit côté sympa à l'événement est donc
en fait après les deux premiers jours de
double l'europe elle était menée 2 4
points 10 à 6 et encore le dernier
double du samedi après-midi c'était
poulter avec mcelroy et poulter avait
fait mais quelque chose de dingue avec
cinq birdies sur les six derniers trous
plus tard en ryder cup c'est vraiment un
phénomène chaque année et donc il avait
accroché le 10 6 à la fin des deux
premières journées
je suppose qu'après poulter avait dû
transcender ses coéquipiers dans le
vestiaire et le lendemain du coup le
dernier jour le dimanche c'était un vrai
miracle
d'où le surnom miracle de médina données
sûrement par les européens puisque les
américains ils ont encore en travers de
la gorge imagine être battus sur leurs
terres avec temps avance et donc du coup
le dernier jour où je me rappelle bien
selon potes de justin rose l'a 15 mètres
gauche droite en descente
pour gagner le trou et au 18 rebelote
peut-être quatre mètres pour birdie de
nouveau et des remporté son simple et
c'était km/heure qui avait permis
de gagner la ryder explosion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]